a different cause but similar scenes
as French protesters Ram a message home
this time supposedly Environmental
in San Celine in the west of France
police footage shows an apparent mix of
genuine climate change protesters and
violent disruptors
today as I see images of the extreme
violence against the police of this
nation I want to give them my full
support and to say we are at their side
and that these violent outbursts are
absolutely Unforgivable
the demonstration was against plans to
build a large water reservoir for Farm
irrigation after the driest winter on
record and a drought last year but
families described being trapped in
clouds of tear gas as police said around
1 000 known troublemakers from across
Europe took over using explosives and
carrying weapons
[Applause]
those scenes Echo and rest in Paris and
across the country in recent days
in separate protests against President
macron's plans to raise the retirement
age to 64. all amid growing condemnation
over police violence it's been a
troubled week in France with protests
all over the country and a nation now
bracing itself for another big day of
strikes over pension reform next week
meanwhile police and protesters have
been injured and more like this is
expected
some now criticizing the violent turn of
demonstrations as distracting from wider
issues at the heart of French Resistance
sweeping the country Adele Robinson Sky
News France